each day since the protests began Haider
rutted has been working this stretch
near Tahrir Square selling Iraqi flags
for less than a dollar each
the teenager dropped out of school when
he was eight to help support his family
he says typically he would stand on a
Main Street in the capital all day
selling water but with Iraqis patriotic
fervor flags have become big business we
want a new country better than this one
ruled by a Dale Abdul Maddy
he killed young men every time young
people come to buy flags and go back
they start shooting live ammunition
Safa Elsa Rai is one of the nearly 280
protesters killed in Iraq since October
1st protesters say they're fed up with
corruption and a lack of jobs and
they're demanding the government's
resignation Elsa rice friends say a tear
gas canister hit his head last week
while he was trying to protect other
protesters under attack on a nearby
bridge it has affected us greatly
he was an irreplaceable person because
he was educated and had a strong impact
on the street especially among young
people the protesters have started a
radio station and are publishing this
newspaper it's named tuk-tuk after the
automated rickshaws that are
transporting the wounded medics and
supplies in and out of tuk we're square
with the Internet blackout the last few
days they've been forced offline and are
now printing these old fashioned
newspapers it's a way for Iraqis to
create a document of their experiences
locking the Internet is a catastrophe
it's equal to a pressing shooting and
killing the authorities have totally
isolated us from the world and started
killing us a spokesman with the Iraqi
military says social media sites are
showing killing and hatred that are
poisoning the minds of youth almost
daily men in Tahrir stopped to tell us
if they died during these protests at
least they would have achieved something
greater than the dead end existed
they've been living Natacha guy named al
jazeera Baghdad